hey leute ich denke mal die meisten von
euch haben schon mitbekommen in den
letzten wochen bin ich häufiger für
christoph als praktikant eingesprungen
und hab ja quasi die videos für ihn
übernommen wenn er gerade halten kann
ich konnte und was mich ja echt super
gefreut hat ist das ganze positive
feedback von euch dass ihr gesagt hey du
machst das super fünf praktikanten oder
wir würden sogar gern noch mehr von ihr
sehen also echt super vielen dank dafür
und wegen dieses feedbacks darf ich
jetzt hier auf den kanal klickst du
meine eigene serie machen
das heißt jeden donnerstag um 19 uhr
kommt jetzt ein video von mir alleine
mit meinen themen online und da hab ich
jetzt einfach richtig bock drauf da ein
bisschen meine themen und meine
faszination mit reinzubringen und das
ganze kommt natürlich zusätzlich zu den
zwei videos die christoph schon jede
woche bringt und deshalb wenn ihr bock
drauf habt jeden donnerstag um 19 uhr
einschalten bin ich da nicht und
ansonsten freut es mich besonders sagen
zu können herzlich willkommen zu der
allerersten folge von clixoom watts und
bei clixoom what's on geht es um ein
thema das mich persönlich so sehr
fasziniert und so sehr beschäftigt wie
eigentlich kein anderes thema überhaupt
nämlich die zukunft denn wir leben zu
einem ganz ganz besonderen zeitpunkt auf
dieser erde
denn unsere welt verändert sich mit
exponentiell geschwindigkeit
jeden tag kommen mehr und mehr
erfindungen auf dem markt jeden tag
werden neue physikalische phänomene
entdeckt und jeden tag gibt es auch neue
projekte die gestartet werden die unser
leben verändern sollen
ich bin unglaublich gespannt auf die
zukunft und deshalb möchte ich euch oder
für euch waren sie ein paar fragen
beantworten die mir immer auf der seele
brennen und zwar wie verändert sich
unser leben unser alltag unsere
unterhaltung vielleicht auch in den
nächsten hundert jahren was passiert ich
möchte also in jedem video eine neue
erfindung oder ein projekt vorstellen
dass unglaublich viel potenzial hat und
das sind alles dinge die mich
unglaublich faszinierend und ich hoffe
ich kann euch mit dieser faszination
zumindest ein bisschen anstrengend aber
warte mal wieso leben wir denn zu einer
ganz besonderen zeit ich meine klar
entwickelt sich alles immer weiter und
weiter
aber wieso ist denn genau dieser
zeitpunkt ganz besonders denn mehr und
mehr erfindungen wird es auch immer
später noch geben oder wenn man sich
eine grafik zum technischen fortschritt
der menschheit zu jedem zeitpunkt
ansehen würde dann sieht das ganze in
etwa so aus und wir sind hier krass oder
wieso sind die kommenden entdeckungen
der nächsten jahrzehnte nicht das
gesprächsthema nummer eins
wieso rastet nicht jeder aus bei dem
gedanken dass sich in den nächsten 30
jahren mehr verändern wird als in den
letzten 2000 jahren
weil wir nur dass hier sehen können und
wir können nicht in die zukunft sehen
und das sieht natürlich ziemlich normal
aus eigentlich aber stellt euch einmal
vor wir reisen mit einer zeitmaschine in
das jahr 1750
wir nehmen uns dort einen
durchschnittlichen typen mit und wir
zeigen ihm unser 2015 mit unglaublich
schnellen magischen blechkisten die über
den boden gleiten können mit geräten die
perfekte gemälde innerhalb von einer
sekunde malen können um den menschen die
gestern noch einfach so in amerika waren
um vielleicht ganz normal zu arbeiten
dieser mann er wäre nicht erstaunt oder
der wenig ungläubig der typ würde
vielleicht vor schock wirklich sterben
wenn wir jetzt aber annehmen dass er
neidisch wird und jemanden 250 jahre vor
seiner zeit ins jahr 1750 holen würde
was würde dann passieren ich meine klar
1500 und 1700 50 das sind extrem
unterschiedliche jahre
neue physikalische erkenntnisse und
imperialismus das sind bestimmt
gewöhnungsbedürftige dinge aber sterben
würde der mann aus 1500 bestimmten nicht
dafür müssen wir schon in die zeit der
nomaden zurückreisen holz und
steinhaufen in den menschen dauerhaft
leben und äcker die jedes jahr aufs neue
bestellt werden können
das wäre für einen steinzeitmenschen
schon extrem heftig ihr seht also die
zeitabstände in denen so viel neues
passiert das ist für ein menschliches
gehirn überhaupt nicht mehr erfassbar
ist in denen die welt sich so sehr
verändert hat dass menschen vielleicht
sterben würden vor schock diese
zeitabstände die werden immer kleiner
menschlicher fortschritt ist
exponentiell er beschleunigt sich immer
schneller und schneller
und ich meine das ist ja auch nur
logisch denn je mehr wissen und zur
verfügung steht desto leichter fällt es
uns auch neues und tiefer gehendes
wissen zu erlangen
ich denke mal als kind haben glaube ich
die meisten von uns wochen oder sogar
monate gebraucht um die vier
grundrechenarten zu kapieren
und jetzt wo wir mehr erfahrung haben
und schon viel über mathematik gelernt
haben da fällt es uns auch relativ
leicht sogar komplexere dinge wie zb das
wurzelziehen zu verstehen
und dafür brauchen wir auch keine monate
mehr es geht also immer schneller und
schneller
das gesamte wissen der menschheit hat
sich über das komplette neunzehnte
jahrhundert hinweg verdoppelt
heute verdoppelt sich das wissen der
menschheit im durchschnitt alle achtung
13 monate und laut ibm wird das internet
der dinge dazu führen dass sich alle
zwölf stunden also zweimal am tag der
komplette informationsgehalt der
menschheit fand doppeln wird was ich
meine und ich meine das sagt nicht
irgendein verrückter wissenschaftler
sondern ibm eine der weltweit
erfolgreichsten firmen und die versuchen
sich im moment auf diese datenflut
vorzubereiten
viele von euch kennen vielleicht das
mooresche gesetz es besagt dass sich die
rechenleistung von mikrochips alle 18
bis 24 monate je nach angaben verdoppelt
und seit 1965 wo das gesetz das erste
mal quasi postuliert wurde ist genau das
eingetreten
der erfinder und wissenschaftler ray
kurzweil geht sogar noch einen schritt
weiter er hat die these aufgestellt dass
das muscial gesetzt nur ein kleiner teil
eines noch viel größeren phänomens ist
nämlich dem dass der fortschritt der
technologie überhaupt nicht aufzuhalten
ist wenn eine technologie nicht mehr
verbessert werden kann
dann wird sie irgendwann durch etwas
besseres ersetzt wenn also unseren
digitalen computer mit einzeln und mit 0
wenn die irgendwann an ihre grenzen
stoßen und das soll übrigens schon sehr
bald passieren nämlich im jahr 2022
dann werden quantencomputer eingesetzt
die noch viel besser sind
ich denke mal viele menschen glauben gar
nicht daran dass sich unsere zukunft so
sehr verändern wird
ich meine es klingt ja auch schon sehr
stark nach einem cyber roman und nicht
nach der echten welt wenn ich euch sage
dass ihr vielleicht 150 oder 200 jahre
alt werden oder vielleicht sogar dass
sie überhaupt nicht sterben werdet dann
schüttet ihr bestimmt mit dem kopf aber
wieso wieso ist das so es ist
unglaublich schwer wenn nicht sogar
unmöglich sich etwas vorzustellen was
noch nicht erfunden wurde
wir menschen greifen immer auf unsere
erfahrungen zurück und die haben uns
gesagt bisher ist noch überhaupt kein
mensch nicht gestorben
jedes lebewesen auf dieser erde ist bis
jetzt gestorben aber bevor das flugzeug
gefunden wurde war ja auch jedem klar
dass menschen hundertprozentig nicht
fliegen können oder
dazu kommt noch dass wir menschen uns
exponentielles wachstum sehr schlecht
vorstellen können wir denken dass das
momentane wachstum linear weitergehen
wird dabei beschleunigt es sich immer
schneller und schneller
statt 123 heißt es eigentlich 124
ich meine das ging jetzt im moment noch
nicht nach besonders viel aber wenn man
bis 30 gezählt hat dann sind die
menschen
wir denken immer noch bei 30 und das
exponentielle wachstum der echten welt
ist bei einer milliarde
ich freue mich unglaublich auf die
zukunft denn sie kommen viel schneller
auf uns zu als die allermeisten von uns
erwarten und ich bin schon unglaublich
gespannt auf die erfindungen die das
leben aller menschen und aller tiere
hier auf der erde
hoffentlich verbessern werden und jetzt
habe ich noch einen super tipp für euch
denn wenn euch das thema zukunft genauso
fasziniert mich und wenn ihr das video
bis jetzt gerade geguckt hat dann wird
euch dieses buch hier nämlich der circle
bestimmt sehr gut gefallen
es geht um ein sehr mächtiges
unternehmen namens der circle wer hätte
das erraten die firma erinnert mich
irgendwie immer ein bisschen an google
denn der circle ist in einiger hinsicht
mächtiger als jede nation super
spannendes kleines buch das ich euch auf
jeden fall empfehlen kann
und das beste ist ihr könnt es umsonst
als hörbuch bekommen und könnt euch dann
quasi vorlesen lassen
das ganze geht über audible wenn ihr
dann probe account macht dann bekommt
ihr kostenlos ein hörbuch geschenkt und
selbst wenn ihr euren account danach
wieder löscht könnt ihr dieses hörbuch
verhalten also wenn euch das ganze
interessiert da müsste einfach hier auf
das buch klicken oder den ersten link
unten in der video beschreibung und dann
bekommt ihr dieses kostenlose hörbuch
ansonsten wenn ihr bis hierhin geguckt
hat dann vielen dank für eure
aufmerksamkeit und bis nächsten
donnerstag um 19 uhr hier auf clixoom